Traduttore: Sofia Spangaro
Revisore: Emanuela Abate
Chi mi ha preceduto...
Molti relatori che mi hanno preceduto
sono uomini del futuro.
Io mi sono sempre definito
"un uomo del presente"
proprio perché io credo
che tutto il mio lavoro
non riesca a fare
degli enormi passi in avanti.
Poi ciascuno è chi è, si deve accettare.
Io molto spesso faccio dei passi laterali
cioè cerco di vedere
le cose che vediamo tutti,
il quotidiano, quello di cui si parla,
semplicemente con un punto di vista
assolutamente personale.
Mi occupo di spazio,
mi sono laureato in architettura,
e faccio design, perché poi
è stato un po' il destino
di tutti quelli della mia generazione
quindi, quando guardo questo tavolo,
semplicemente mi sposto lateralmente
e diventa questa roba qua.
È una specie
di atto di magia, nel senso...
Il titolo che vi ho proposto era
"La forma come contenuto", no?
Io mi immagino sempre un cilindro
però il cilindro del prestigiatore.
Il contenuto del cilindro
è un coniglio bianco.
Quindi "la forma come contenuto"
in questo senso, cioè c'è sempre
una seconda lettura, un secondo messaggio.
Questo è un tavolo che rinuncia
alle quattro gambe portanti.
Perlomeno, non è che rinuncia,
scommette, esagera:
quattro sono portanti,
171 restanti sono morbide.
Quindi è anche una specie
di gioco di prestigio
perché la linea esterna,
perimetrale, è tutta morbida.
Quindi la gente, mi ricordo,
quando nel 2001
abbiamo presentato
al Salone del Mobile,
le toccava e pensava che
questo tavolo semplicemente galleggiasse
perché erano tante le gambe
anche se erano morbide.
Ma poi io in fondo progetto questi tavoli
semplicemente perché sono teatri di storie
che possono accadere:
questo era lo schizzo con cui
ho presentato il progetto a Cappellini.
A me interessava quello
che succede sotto al tavolo.
Quindi ogni cosa è vettore,
una forma come contenuto.
Poi, voglio dire,
noi abbiamo giocato tanto
con l'idea della piazza.
L'idea della piazza è la più grande
idea architettonica italiana.
Questo luogo d'incontro.
Forse il maggiore prodotto
d'esportazione architettonica italiano.
Per me si riduce in scala 1:250
ed entra nei salotti delle persone
perché un po' ci siamo dimenticati
il senso della piazza
ma è semplicemente anche questo
un gioco di magia, una semplice piroetta,
un movimento laterale che serve
a riportare al centro dell'attenzione
un tema come quello della piazza.
Oppure vado in piazza Gino Valle a Milano,
dove gli edifici sono fatti così:
sono disegnati da Gino Valle stesso,
a cui è dedicata la piazza,
e per fare un edificio
come sede della squadra del Milan
decido che questa forma, in fondo,
deve essere semplicemente portatrice,
vettore di un contenuto.
Quindi questi atleti
corrono sul tetto del soffitto,
impattano con una palla, quindi
quella roba lì diventa messaggio,
è la "man, motion, emotion".
Però è esattamente trattare anche
la superficie di un edificio non mio
come una tela.
In fondo, veramente,
è sempre un passetto laterale.
Questa è un'architettura
nel giardino fantastico di Bomarzo
che mi ha sempre colpito.
Io guardo il mio quotidiano,
perché poi ciascuno, scusate,
se lo sceglie, il quotidiano:
non è che necessariamente
da qui a casa vostra
fate sempre la stessa strada.
Io faccio sempre strade diverse.
Quindi questo
è il mio quotidiano, in fondo.
Io elaboro il mio quotidiano,
faccio il passetto laterale,
e diventa questa roba qui:
questo è un lavoro che ho fatto
per l'ultima Triennale, la XXI.
In fondo non ho fatto altro
che estroflettere Bomarzo.
La gente entrava
in questo igloo specchiato
ed entrava dentro la mia testa.
Infatti quelle orecchie lì
erano dei grandi amplificatori
da cui uscivano parole estratte
da un libro che ho scritto io
e si intitola
Il design spiegato a mia madre
quindi praticamente un ossimoro
perché vi assicuro che non si può
spiegare il design a vostra madre,
assolutamente non si può.
Vostra madre, quando provate
a spiegarle qualcosa,
mia madre purtroppo è morta,
ma quando provavo a spiegarle qualcosa
lei sorrideva e diceva:
"Fabio, cosa vuoi mangiare?".
Quindi è semplicemente
questa roba qui, no?
Allora, io provo a spiegarlo
attraverso le orecchie della mia testa,
la gente entra dentro
e gli racconto un po' di storie
insieme a un testo di 8½ di Fellini.
Io sono molto attratto dai visi,
dai volti, dalle maschere:
in fondo sono il nostro
vero biglietto da visita, no?
Noi ci esprimiamo
con tantissima mimica facciale.
Questa è la maschera
tipica del teatro greco.
Questa maschera serviva
a celare i volti reali degli attori
quindi comunque a dar loro
delle connotazioni artificiali
ma aveva anche un altro uso,
assolutamente interessante:
serviva per amplificare la voce.
Uno non ci crede:
io adesso ho questo microfono
che volgarmente viene detto "gelato"
anche se non si lecca
ma pensate: nel teatro greco
erano enormi gli spazi aperti
quindi c'era bisogno di questi aggeggi
che amplificavano
quasi magicamente la voce.
Anche lì la magia mi interessa moltissimo.
Insomma questa maschera
diventa una maschera un po' fuori scala
per il nostro quotidiano
e qui sovviene un'altra cosa,
anche lì, il mio quotidiano
sono state delle letture di Oscar Wilde
e mi imbattei in questa frase
che mi colpì moltissimo:
"Tutti gli uomini mentono
ma dategli una maschera
e diranno la verità."
Allora Nemo serve per dire la verità
e questi occhi a me sanno di verità.
Io sono molto affascinato
da David Bowie come artista,
abbiamo davvero perso
una persona che ci ha dato tantissimo
quindi quando un cliente mi ha chiesto
di fare uno showroom
di rivestimenti in mosaico a Berlino,
ho pensato alla sua trilogia di Berlino.
Lui ha fatto tre album
in due anni, '77 e '78,
tre album epici.
Allora ho messo i suoi grandi occhi
di due colori diversi in vetrina
di uno showroom di mosaici.
Quindi, voi dite, sempre
questo spostamento laterale
la trasfigurazione della realtà,
guardare alla realtà con occhi diversi,
semplicemente occhi diversi,
in questo caso
con gli occhi di David Bowie.
Questa è un'immagine
che ho preso da Internet stamattina:
mi serviva un'immagine di due pilastri.
Questi sono esattamente i due pilastri
in cui mi sono imbattuto
quando mi sono trovato
a fare questo locale:
questo è un locale a Milano
fatto un bel po' di anni fa,
quindici, vent'anni fa.
Avevo questi due pilastri ma
semplicemente questi pilastri
per me sorreggevano il palazzo
che c'era sopra questo locale
allora diventavano
le braccia di questo dio.
Anche lì stavo leggendo
il testo sacro dei morti egizio.
C'era questo dio che si chiamava Shu
che reggeva la volta celeste
e allora questi due pilastri
erano immediatamente diventati
le braccia del dio Shu e sorreggevano
la volta di questo locale a Milano.
Oppure, voglio dire, ci si imbatte...
Il mio quotidiano è anche
visitare mostre, amare artisti...
Io amo tantissimo De Chirico,
allora le sue piazze d'Italia...
Ne ha fatte centinaia
di piazze d'Italia, sono ossessioni...
Gli artisti sono ossessionati,
sono dei maniaci ossessivi evidentemente.
E per me diventa questa roba qui.
Cioè, la diretta relazione...
Io guardo De Chirico,
mi sposto lateralmente,
socchiudo un po' gli occhi,
perché poi è sempre
questa capacità di trasfigurazione...
Ragazzi, la progettazione
è trasfigurazione.
E diventa questa roba qua.
Oppure guardo Tiziano.
Questo è del 1538, era bellissimo.
Pensate a Tiziano.
Pensate a tutti gli artisti
della sua epoca.
Prendevano queste donne,
quasi sempre, per la maggioranza
prostitute dalla strada,
le facevano stendere su un triclinio,
le dipingevano e le trasformavano in dee,
perché tutti questi quadri si chiamavano:
Venere alle acque, La dea seduta,
quindi la divinizzazione della prostituta.
Era il top, questo è totale
potere di trasfigurazione,
esattamente quello
che accade con l'arte, no?
Io ho cercato di farlo con questo divano.
Tra l'altro qui mi interessava
anche il fatto di superare
la soglia dell'opera artistica,
quindi di valicare la barriera.
Per me quello è fondamentale,
cioè non pensare che
l'opera d'arte sia altro da sé
quanto in qualche maniera interagire,
farla propria, attraversare la soglia.
Forse quello è l'unico passo in avanti
che mi piace, invece che laterale,
cioè varcare la soglia dell'opera.
Andiamo avanti. Questo è...
Io parlo sempre di punto di vista:
uomo italiano eterosessuale,
quindi il femminino è sempre negli occhi
e nei desideri di un uomo.
Questa è la mia prima architettura,
pensate, è stato il primo lavoro
in cui queste gambe di donna,
che sono sempre una specie di goal
per qualsiasi uomo, diventano
la soglia di un negozio di moda.
Oppure il quotidiano
può essere uno stilista
come Tommy Hilfiger
- questa è una pubblicità delle sue -
che mi aveva chiesto
di fare una vetrina speciale
per questo lancio a Milano etc. etc.
Ne approfitti anche, eventualmente,
per fare un passetto di critica.
Gli dici: "Tommy Hilfiger, mio caro,
tu in fondo non fai altro
che proporre lifestyle alla gente,
non sono altro che dei kit di montaggio
di un immaginario come questo."
Quindi qualsiasi passo laterale
lo decidi tu.
Qualsiasi punto di vista
lo decidi tu, come progettista,
e ne fai quello che vuoi.
Io quando vedo
questa macchina
che alla gente fa impazzire...
Io non sono per niente
appassionato di macchine,
non possiedo una macchina,
per me, quando mi chiedono di fare...
Quella è una Mustang.
Però mi piace il nome, "Mustang",
mustang è un cavallo selvaggio, no?
Allora quando mi chiedono
di fare lo stesso oggetto
per un produttore
di giocattolini in legno per bambini,
la Mustang diventa un cavallo vero, no?
Tra l'altro pensate a questo.
Piccola divagazione:
è incredibile che ancora noi giudichiamo
il potere di un motore in horse power,
cioè noi ancora siamo così legati
ad una vecchia logica
di trasporto con l'animale equino
da trasformare ogni potere di qualsiasi
autoveicolo, persino di una Ferrari...
Cinquecento cavalli, dal cofano
apri e escono cinquecento cavalli.
Quindi quando vedo quella macchina lì,
per me è questa roba qua.
Trasfigurazione pura.
Oppure quando vedo questo:
nella nostra città siamo abituatissimi
a questo tipo di "panorama".
Per me questo panorama qua
diventa quest'altra cosa.
Questo è successo qualche anno fa.
Il sindaco di Milano mi chiese
di risolvere il problema
che c'era a Montenapoleone:
mancanza di verde e parcheggio selvaggio.
Semplice: mixi le due cose,
ti sposti lateralmente,
le auto diventano il vaso perfetto
replicato in vetroresina,
e te le fai pagare da Fiat perché
doveva fare il lancio della 500 Cabrio.
Quindi il cerchio si chiude sempre.
Lo devi chiudere, come progettista,
perché in fondo dobbiamo
portare a casa il risultato.
Non so se avete sentito, se avete letto
il discorso di ringraziamento
di Bob Dylan al premio Nobel.
Lui dice: "Uno non è che fa le cose
perché pensa di vincere
il premio Nobel per la Letteratura".
Lui si è un po' paragonato a Shakespeare.
Lui dice: "Shakespeare,
secondo voi, si preoccupava
di quanto sarebbe piaciuto ai critici
o di quanto sarebbe arrivato ai posteri?"
Si preoccupava di: "Sul palco ci entra
l'attrice che deve recitare il ruolo?",
"Il teschio per Amleto:
vero, finto, chi lo fa?"
Una macchina 3D, se ci fosse stata.
I problemi sono più contingenti,
quindi questo far quadrare i conti,
questa è la vera quotidianità.
Questo è il vero mestiere del progettista.
Il suo spostarsi di lato
e scegliersi il punto di vista.
Andiamo avanti.
Oppure questo.
Questo tra l'altro accade spesso
nelle strade dissestate
della nostra Italia.
E per me diventa
questa roba qui.
Tra l'altro è l'occasione
di una storia da raccontare
perché questo è un progetto
che io ho intitolato Green Line
in onore di una mia visita a Beirut
dove ad un certo punto...
Fate conto che questa città pazzesca
si era spezzata in due
perché da una parte c'erano i cattolici,
e dall'altra c'erano i musulmani.
Si sparavano da una parte
all'altra della barricata
Fate conto: voi siete i cattolici,
voi i musulmani,
in questa strada in mezzo
non ci passava più nessuno
e nel manto d'asfalto
iniziavano a crescere le piante
quindi questa strada fu ribattezzata
Green Line, "la linea verde",
un po' come la "linea verde"
che Boeri sogna per Milano.
Però è bellissimo
che un fiore con la sua forza
attraversi lo strato d'asfalto
e riacquisti dignità
e provi ad insegnare agli esseri umani
la spesso assoluta insensatezza.
Oppure guardo ai vicoli di Napoli
e mi viene da dire...
Io vivo a Milano,
dove ci sono le strade più eleganti
e le strade del Quadrilatero della Moda
e appena ne ho l'occasione
"napoletanizzo" Milano.
Questa è via della Spiga, nello specifico.
Questo è un intervento fatto
per le luminarie di qualche anno fa.
L'Assessore chiamò
una serie di progettisti,
mi assegnò via della Spiga
e io decisi di replicare
Spaccanapoli in via della Spiga
con degli elementi fatti
completamente di diodi luminosi.
Oppure decido
di prendere l'oggetto feticcio
della mia gioventù da designer
di affrontarlo
prendendo in prestito un personaggio
dal Simposio di Platone.
Il Simposio di Platone è un libro in cui
ciascuno dà un'interpretazione dell'amore.
C'è questo drammaturgo che
a un certo punto racconta questa storia:
l'essere umano è un essere
perfetto, felicissimo, asessuato,
è così felice che dà fastidio agli dei.
Gli dei si lamentano
con Zeus e, per farvela breve,
Zeus li fa venire tutti in fila,
questi caspita di esseri umani,
e con delle saette li divide a metà,
costringendoli quindi
a ritrovare la perfezione originaria
semplicemente ritrovando
la complementarietà
del mascolino e del femminino.
Quindi io che ho sempre
considerato perfetta la Panton Chair
faccio Zeus e la spezzo in due,
la spezzo in him and her.
E questo è un altro spostamento laterale,
è un altro punto di vista.
La perfezione in fondo non esiste.
La ricerchiamo sempre inseguendoci
sulla superficie del pianeta.
Siamo sempre un po'
Adamo ed Eva che si cercano.
Oppure guardiamo quest'altro.
Ciascuno passa attraverso
fasi di assestamento,
stadi evolutivi, diciamo.
Questo è un divano
che mi ricorda moltissimo
i miei anni a New York.
Io ho sempre detto,
quando vivevo a New York,
che i barboni, i clochard,
chiamateli come volete, gli homeless
sono i veri padroni delle città.
Perché si appropriano
di qualsiasi cosa che è per strada.
Noi in fondo non consideriamo
lo spazio pubblico come uno spazio nostro.
Lo spazio pubblico è dove
casomai lanciamo la carta per terra,
non ce ne curiamo
mentre loro sono
i veri padroni della città.
In fondo dovremmo imparare molto da loro.
Quando ho proposto questo divano
a Cappellini gli ho detto:
"Giulio, questa roba qui è adaptation,
è esattamente l'adattamento
alle avversità delle condizioni,
il trovare comodità
in qualsiasi punto di rottura,
ed è quello che ci consente
di andare avanti, no?
Oppure, questo è un altro divano
che ho disegnato sempre per Cappellini,
pensate che io... è un po'
adaptation anche questa cosa qui.
Io avevo disegnato
solo questo elemento qui
che non sta in piedi.
E questa è una cosa
che mi interessa spiegarvi.
È come un "io".
"Io" non sta in piedi.
Dico sempre che, anche linguisticamente,
l'"io" è contenuto nel "noi".
Se voi specchiate "noi"
è "io" all'ennesima, no?
"Io" all'ennesima potenza.
"Noi" ha senso soltanto
se tanti "io" si mettono assieme.
Quindi questo divano non è altro
che tanti moduli messi assieme
che si possono unire all'infinito
e creare un divano per far sedere chiunque
Tra l'altro viene usato adesso
molto nelle hall degli aeroporti.
Si chiama AND. And è la congiunzione.
Io e te e te e te e te e te.
Tra l'altro AND al contrario è DNA,
una specie di...
di catena, di genoma diverso
per una generazione
più condivisiva, se volete.
Oppure la tua quotidianità
è anche fatta di riferimenti classici:
la chaise longue di Le Corbusier,
il famoso lettino
della psicanalisi di Sigmund Freud,
e queste sono le macchie di Rorschach,
i test di Rorschach...
ti fanno vedere questi test
e tu devi dare delle
interpretazioni di queste macchie.
Per me diventano questa cosa qui
quindi mi autoanalizzo.
Tra l'altro è interessante, ragazzi,
che nei primi del Novecento,
fine Ottocento - primi del Novecento,
Freud era il fighissimo
del suo periodo storico
quindi quella roba lì che
il giovane Le Corbusier disegna nel '28
non è altro che figlia
esattamente di quel lettino.
Quindi è interessante come il design
un po' risenta evidentemente
degli influssi culturali,
delle mode, diciamo,
perché Freud era il re, a quel tempo,
la psicanalisi era la disciplina regina,
cioè molto di più delle stampanti 3D,
era la nanotecnologia del momento.
Insomma, questa roba qui diventa Lapsus:
quindi prendo il divano di Freud, lo fondo
con la chaise longue di Le Corbusier,
e cambio tutti i pattern persiani
del tappeto di Freud
con le macchie di Rorschach.
Oppure prendo la bandiera americana.
Non trasfigurando - semplicemente
un po' socchiudendo gli occhi.
Diventa questa roba qui,
che è uno showroom che ho fatto
in tempi non sospetti di bushismo.
Adesso sarebbe quasi
da replicare per Trump, ma insomma...
Semplicemente disassemblando la bandiera.
O, rimanendo nel tema delle bandiere,
il comune di Milano qualche anno fa
mi chiese di fare un padiglione
per Shanghai che rappresentasse la città.
Allora ci si interroga su quello
che è la croce rossa in campo bianco.
Ti accorgi che
la croce rossa era la nobiltà,
il campo bianco era il popolo.
E che cos'è la nobiltà di una città oggi?
La nobiltà è la nobiltà creativa, e allora
ci metti Boccioni, i tagli di Fontana,
attenti che Boccioni e Fontana
non erano milanesi
quindi che cos'è anche lì
la forma come contenuto?
È diritto di terra e non di sangue.
Tu stai affermando
con un'aggiunta di destra
che comunque il simbolo della città
è la croce rossa in campo bianco
reinterpretata con le eccellenze
di Milano che non sono milanesi.
Un po' in barba alla Lega.
E qui c'è tra l'altro Miuccia Prada,
qua c'è l'Ultima Cena di Leonardo,
che non era milanese
ma la fa a Milano.
E anche lì, questo
è dal Manuale degli Architetti,
l'unica cosa che sono riuscito
a trovare su Internet
perché ora il Manuale degli Architetti
è praticamente in disuso,
è materia preistorica.
Sta di fatto che è un po'
l'approccio ai ripiani.
Però questo mi fa venire in mente
quando arriva questo cliente americano,
mi dice: "Fabio, vorrei fare un negozio
di scarpe", e gli faccio questa roba qui
perché in fondo è semplicemente
rapportarsi a una mensola nello spazio
la fai impazzire, socchiudi gli occhi,
e diventa questo reticolo
un po' favolistico, un po' immaginario,
un po' magico, perché a me
la parola "magia" piace tantissimo.
Guardate, io non credevo tanto alla magia.
Un amico qualche anno fa
mi ha omaggiato di un biglietto
per vedere David Copperfield.
Secondo me mi ero dimenticato
perché poi l'età adulta
ti fa dimenticare una serie di cose.
Allora ero andato lì dicendo:
"Ah, 'sto Copperfield, 'sto ciarlatano..."
Mi ha messo in prima fila,
questo mio amico, abbastanza fortunato.
Questo David Copperfield
alla vostra distanza
mi ha fatto cadere la mascella
cioè è una roba...
Lasciarsi travolgere
dalla magia è bellissimo
ed è così infantile come approccio,
è sempre l'occhio del bambino...
ecco perché vi ho detto che per me
nel cilindro c'è sempre il coniglio bianco
Andiamo avanti.
Guardi un gesto così
e diventa questa cosa qui.
Questi sono anni di sperimentazione
sempre con questo produttore di mosaico
che si chiama Bisazza.
Questo era uno stand fieristico,
ragazzi, uno stand fieristico
per un produttore di mosaici.
Quindi ciascuno
può intrecciare interpretazioni,
ciascuno può far diventare
quotidiano o straordinario qualsiasi cosa.
Questa è una maniglia
che mi ero comprato in casa
quando avevo fatto casa mia.
Avevo detto, la voglio semplicissima,
il tondino di metallo...
Però avendola sempre
sotto gli occhi ho detto:
"Ma il tondino di metallo
non mi accontenta"
quindi ho semplicemente asportato materia
e questa materia ha originato un cuore.
Questo perché
-- piccola microstoria all'interno --
per me disegnare la maniglia
era il progetto più difficile
perché odio le porte,
mi fanno proprio schifo le porte,
le divisioni, le barriere,
non riesco a sopportarle.
Quindi disegnare una maniglia
era quasi una contraddizione in termini,
evidentemente.
E qui il titolo di questa maniglia
come molte volte per qualsiasi opera
spiega tanto le intenzioni.
Love Opens Doors,
soltanto l'amore apre le porte.
Quindi non basta impugnare un tondino
ma devi togliere materia al tondino,
disegnare un cuore e impugnare un cuore.
E queste sono le copertine
di due monografie fatte negli anni passati
però anche questa è trasfigurazione pura.
A quel tempo mi piaceva mettere
la mia immagine in copertina.
Poi semplicemente ho detto:
"Ma che senso ha? Io mi vedo così,
io mi vedo che socchiudo gli occhi,
faccio un passo laterale, mi apro il petto
trovo un fiore dentro di me
e lo dono all'interlocutore".
E questa è forse l'interpretazione
in cui mi riconosco di più.
Guardate, per chiudere,
io non sono certo che
l'evoluzione sia un passo in avanti,
ma sono certo che
l'evoluzione sia un passo di danza.
Quindi godetevela.
Ciao.